This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s,
the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So today, we're talking about something that I can pretty much guarantee you've experienced at some point in your life, maybe even today in the past week, in the past hour. Today we are talking about intrusive thoughts. And when you hear that, you might immediately think we're going to be talking about OCD again. That's definitely a big element of it. But in reality, the majority of people
experience intrusive thoughts on a daily basis without having OCD. And they can feel really, really scary, really hard to let go of, just so confronting. And I think when you don't know why they're happening or what they mean, that fear can become even more intense. One of the biggest pieces of evidence of how common this actually is comes from a massive international study led by this guy called Adam Radomsky and his colleagues where they interviewed over 700 students across 13 countries using a very structured interview process. And they found that amongst these students, 93.6% reported experiencing an intrusive thought in the last three months alone. And that estimate may actually be kind of on the lower side.
Another study found 99.4% of participants interviewed, had experienced an intrusive thought in the last three months to six months. They can feel so shocking, so shocking that it can be hard to, you know, admit to them or talk openly about them, but they're also an incredibly normal part of the human experience that is linked to everything from very minor stress to health anxiety, to postpartum depression, PTSD, eating disorders. And sometimes they just are entirely random for like no other reason. The good news is we actually have some really helpful mechanisms for managing intrusive thoughts.
And some very smart people have been on this for a while. And they've come up with some great ways to kind of take the sting out of them. And I think just firstly understanding why the heck your brain just throws these weird thoughts at you is honestly the first step to feeling less afraid of them. So that is exactly what we're going to do here, break down the psychology of intrusive thoughts, break down their structure where they occur and also how to move past them. So stay with us. So I've spoken about this on the podcast before, but I've had intrusive thoughts for years.
Intrusive thoughts like, what if I accidentally ran over my dog? And like I didn't realize it. When I was younger especially, I would like obsessively believe that I had committed some grave sin without realizing it. So I'd have to pray in a very specific way every night to be forgiven. Another one that I think is really common that I get is like weird graph. images from the news or from videos will like suddenly appear in my mind and like linger on. My brain has two favorite intrusive thoughts of late. We can laugh at them together.
The first is that if anyone is looking at me on the tube or in public, I begin to think that I've just screamed really loud and forgotten about it. And now they're all watching me to make sure I like, don't do it again, which makes me want to scream. and then I feel like any second I'm going to do it again, crazy. Secondly, the other intrusive thought that I've been having is that anytime I order Uber eats, someone has poisoned my food. I literally threw out like $30 worth of sushi the other night because I was convinced that
because the lid had felt fallen off, it had been poisoned. Who exactly is out to poison me? I have no idea. That's not the point. They're super bizarre. super weird and the reason I give these examples and I have many many more is because it shows something really important about the nature of these thoughts by nature they are unwanted they are taboo sometimes they are against our values but specifically they're against how we want
to live or how we want to be perceived or what we actually want to think about the defining features that can help you determine is this an intrusive thought or I guess normal thought is it's unwanted. You don't want to be thinking about it. It's involuntary. You didn't choose to think about it. It interrupts your thought process. It doesn't just pass naturally.
And it tends to be attached to some kind of emotion, whether that is anxiety, disgust, dread, shame, guilt is another big one. This is very different to what we call, impulsive thoughts, but they kind of operate in a similar space. People often, like, confuse, intrusive and impulsive thoughts. So I think it's really important, you know, the difference. Impulsive thoughts are erratic, and they go something like, I want to knock that cup off the table, and then you actually, you go and do it. Or like, what if I just dyed my hair black tonight?
or what if I just did actually place that $500 close order? They're not inherently harmful in the way that acting on an intrusive thought would be harmful. And they also don't cause us significant distress. They're very often associated with ADHD or impulse control conditions. But because they enter our mind sometimes just as fast and dramatically as an intrusive thought, we can confuse them and believe that they are the same thing. This is where I think it actually gets scary. Because you might have a mix of both intrusive and impulsive thoughts,
and because you sometimes might act on your impulsive thoughts, you start to think that eventually you could act on your intrusive thoughts. And that thought in itself, that idea that that could happen is in itself just terrifying. So it's important to note they are very, very, very, different, even if they feel like they have similar structures. The key thing is intrusive thoughts are not intentions. They're not desires the same way that an impulsive thought might be. Intentions involve choice and they involve endorsement. And intrusions are often the opposite. They are experienced as very alien, very upsetting, very inconsistent with the self. A desire, you just have to
remember this has pulled. There's like a little part of you that wants to pursue it or is excited by it. Most intrusive thoughts have repulsion and they have fear. People feel horrified because they don't want the thought and because the content really hits at something precious that they don't want to injure. That's why they're called ego-dustonic. That's something you'll hear a lot when people talk about intrusive thoughts. They are also not predictions. Let's make that super clear here. Just because you think your house is going to burn down doesn't mean it will. Just because you have intrusive thoughts about death doesn't mean that that is what death is going to look like or feel like.
We buy into these thoughts, not realizing that a thought is not a prophecy. Your brain can generate a scenario without it being likely. meaningful or true. In fact, your brain generates hundreds of thousands of scenarios a day, and yet it cannot magic something into happening, otherwise the whole world's reality would be controlled by you. Do you get what I mean? Like, realizing how absurd it sounds and how absurd the world would be if all our intrusive thoughts or thoughts in general could come true just by us thinking about them, I think makes us realize that they don't and that they won't. Another thing you may have noticed is that intrusive thoughts often have some very common themes
that are just scary. Aggression, harm, sexual content, contamination, things about disease. These things are by nature to our humanity, the core parts of us as humans, very scary, very shocking. That is why it puts them at odds with what we're typically thinking about, and that is why they really stand out. Harm intrusions, I think, are especially common thoughts like that one I gave before. What if I ran over my dog?
What if I just swerve the car and I kill a bunch of people? What if I push somebody? What if I have secretly really hurt somebody? Stabbed them, done something absolutely like just horrendous. Sometimes as well intrusive thoughts show up like almost like a persistent mental replay. of something that we have seen or felt. There's this, it's, it really blows a lot of lines because sometimes they can just be imaginary.
Sometimes it can be a past experience. And PTSD, for example, intrusive experiences are often trauma-related images and memories that just like intrude involuntarily and they feel intensely emotional, sometimes as if the experience is literally happening again. And you are going through it. once more. These days, I actually think we need to be more aware of intrusive memories or intrusive recollections, especially of this violent nature because of the violent stuff we see online. Like, people getting killed, people getting shot, people getting bombed, harmed, violence, like the visual
of that can linger, even if you weren't there, even if you only experienced it through a screen, you can still have an intrusive memory of it. You don't have to have been there. Vicarious trauma through online content is a legit thing that does actually and has been known to lead to intrusive thoughts. So the final one that we need to talk about is taboo intrusion. So things that are sexual, blasphemous, socially unacceptable, specifically where the main emotional experience is often just shame and disgust or, I guess, fear of what it means. In these situations, you know, a thought pops into your head that is so abhorrent and so gross that you think to have thought that you must secretly desire doing it.
That's why it appeared. That's why it caused you to question your morals, whether you're a good person. How could a good person be thinking this? Can people trust you? Do they know what's secretly going on inside your head? It's a really difficult experience. But again, that is why intrusive thoughts are so cruel. They come from your brain, and your brain knows everything about you,
including the things that disgust you or terrify you. it knows exactly how to shock you by taking everything you care about and pulling it all the way to the other direction. Why your brain then decides to play with those thoughts and throw them at you, we're going to get to that in a second. But again, the reason they all cause such intense fear is because by nature they are in direct contradiction to what you value. That's what I really, that's what was important for me to.
know when I was first experiencing this. And that's what I think is really important for us just to remember, even if you've heard it before. You know, if you deeply value safety, that is why your mind produces harm scenarios. If you deeply value morality, that is why your mind produces taboo moral thoughts. If you deeply value your new baby, for example, like, that is why your mind produces horrifying baby harm thoughts or nightmare thoughts about what's going to happen to your child. If you deeply value your relationship, that is why your mind produces those thoughts of, what if I don't actually love them? What if I cheated on them? Those kinds of just rapid intrusions. A thought that didn't carry so much emotional weight wouldn't stick the way intrusive thoughts do,
because your brain wouldn't be so alarmed. And because it is so alarmed, and because it feels such an intense way, that is why, it is so hard to move on from because we think that it must mean something if it could have arisen in the first place. This is when we get to a crucial element of this. The problem isn't the intrusion itself. If we were to simply be able to say, yeah, that's not true. I know that's not true and move on. We'd likely be fine. It's this reaction and this interpretation and our sense of personal responsibility that we have towards this intrusive thought that often then goes on to trigger distress and trigger, I guess, a need for a neutralizing response, a related
concept that you need to know. You need to know here if you are experiencing this is something called thought, action, fusion, which is basically the feeling that having a thought is the moral equivalent to doing it or that thinking it increases like the likelihood. of it happening. Like we were talking about before. We think that there is some predictive value here. This is very similar to the concept of magical thinking, believing that our thoughts have the power to change reality, which is hard because that can be both a good thing to believe in and a horrifying thing to believe in. That belief that our thoughts can change our reality. That is,
that belief is like a cornerstone to manifestation and positive thinking and even like some elements of cognitive behavioral therapy to some extent how you think about something changes how you behave towards it which changes the reality of it um i also feel like this can be a real spiritual concept for some of us believing that we have the power to change things through thought but also that we can sense things that are meant for us before they happen, that we have a destiny, that our thoughts are, I guess, leading us someplace. That's a very spiritually profound thought that a lot of people have. But when you have an intrusive thought or when you have OCD or anything of the sort, that magical thinking becomes pretty unmagical. Because now you imbue every thought with
this added meaning. What if it is a sign? What if it is a message from the universe? What if this is my intuition? You know, what if this is some greater power speaking to me on a deeper level, trying to tell me something? Rationally, like, you know this isn't true. You know that. But when you're also in the state of fear, in the state of panic, about a specific thought,
the logic required to recognize magical thinking, the logic required to interrupt that thinking off into specific. appears. And that itself is a part of this whole process, not having the rationality because you are so afraid to realize that the thought is really what's causing the fear. So you can kind of see the loop we end up in here. You think something and it's scary. And because it's scary, it feels important. So your mind concentrates on it more, which makes it feel more realistic and therefore scarier. It drives me nuts, honestly. You know, at the broadest level, intrusive thoughts, these kinds of intrusive thoughts,
they happen because your brain is a meaning-making, threat-detecting prediction machine. All day, again, your mind generates random associations automatically to try and figure out what is going on around it, to try and make sense out of your daily interactions and daily experiences. It brings up fragments of a memory, mental images, impulsions. and absolute nonsense, just trying to find a good interpretation or a way of ordering things. So it's going to have thousands of good thoughts, bad thoughts, neutral thoughts, scary thoughts, but of course certain categories get tagged as important. The threats, the taboo things, the things to do with responsibility, identity.
Again, these tags, those tags don't mean that the thought is true. It just means that the thought becomes salient. and it just means that your brain pays more attention to it. And because our human threat systems are biased towards better safe than sorry, the mind lingers and will continue to produce catastrophic scenarios to do with this thing that you fear the most, even when nothing is wrong, especially under stress, especially when it feels like if it could overthink this,
if it could linger on this, it could anticipate how to respond and how to, I guess, survive if this were to actually occur. So let's talk about why our mind would think we need testing and thinks we need intrusive thoughts and when they are likely to increase after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with
writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell is?
George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search, Learn the Hardway, and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any map. should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I feel like the moment my intrusive thoughts start increasing, it is like the canary in the coal mine telling me it is time to start taking better care of my mental health and to start taking. better care of myself. Intrusive thoughts do become more common during certain life events. Again, whether you have OCD, whether you have anxiety, PTSD or not, there are times in your life that you are probably going to see an increase in prevalence. The postpartum period is an example that researchers explicitly discuss when it comes to an increase in intrusive thoughts. One of my
friends, she actually recently did have a baby and her intrusive thoughts, like has, had a a major uptick. They increased rapidly. She constantly worried, what was the one she was telling me about, that a cat had broken into her baby's room and was sleeping on her baby's face, which is really weird because she doesn't have a cat. Another one was that she'd accidentally taken another person's baby at the park. That was a big one. Any significant period of hormone fluctuations, like right before you get your period or during perimenopause. Also, if you have significant thyroid issues, research shows intrusive thoughts may be more common for you.
Actually, in 2013, in Australia, they did conduct a study into this and they actually looked into the role of hormones and the formation of intrusive memories. and what they found was that elevated estrogen levels as well as elevated cortisol levels really predicted negative intrusive memories and how many negative intrusive memories people have or had of an event. And it makes sense. It makes sense that that would be the case. Yes, during hormonal fluctuations and that, but also during stress because it's all tied
up together. All these systems are interconnected, right? and the cognitive effort required to dismiss these thoughts and to use our coping strategies and to apply logic and to move forward is greatly fatigued by everything else that is going on. Your brain is magnificent. It also does not have unlimited cognitive and mental resources. If it is being taxed by work, by stress, by relationships, by a recent move, by a recent loss, by a breakup, your defenses aren't as well. So those intrusive thoughts get through the first line of defense.
Another interesting thing to note. Intrusive thoughts are also likely to be more common in those who already have a mind that is primed for threat-focused repetition. What I mean by that is people who worry a lot, people who ruminate a lot, and people who feel a strong need to resolve uncertainty. This is pretty obvious. but people, for example, with a personality trait called the need for closure are more susceptible susceptible to intrusive thoughts than people who don't have that need. And this personality trait, need for closure is what it sounds like. There are some people out there, and we all know them, who can just like adapt to new situations,
who don't need closure from the past, who don't need a plan, who are okay with not having all the answers. and those people tend to have less intrusive thoughts. I'm not one of those people, that's for sure. My need for closure is very high. I want to know. I want to know the answer. So when an intrusive thought pops up that doesn't have an immediate answer, of course I'm going to obsess over it,
because my brain thinks that that's a way of learning more. You can actually take this test. You can measure yourself on the need for closure scale online. I think it's either on the Princeton or Strait. Stanford website. If you're interested, it takes like five minutes. I think from memory, it is free. It's really revealing. It's very validating to know. This is just my brain. When I did that test and I got the score that I got, I can't remember, but it was pretty high. I remember being like, oh God, this makes so much more sense. And it brought me a lot of calm to
know that these thoughts were just a symptom of my operating manual. And again, it put this barrier between me and having to think that every single one of them was real. This was just how my brain worked. I often find it so funny. Funny is the only way to feel about it, that the scariest thing in the world to me is a thought my own brain concocted that has like a 0.0000% chance of coming true. Like again, sometimes you just have to laugh at how absurd and funny it is, that my brain is like getting scared of itself. It's also funny, but equally unfunny, not funny, like this whole thing is that the worst thing you can do for an intrusive thought is to actually not think about them, which is the thing that you most want to do. Like, the worst thing you can do is suppress an
intrusive thought. It sucks, but ignoring them or aggressively trying to suppress them or avoid them which often feels like the only natural thing to do in that situation, that will probably result in them growing and in them spawning two heads and terrorizing you even further. Like this whole, everything to do with intrusive thoughts honestly feels like a big joke. This was something actually demonstrated by an incredibly famous series of studies or a series of experiments from the 1980s by Daniel Wagner and David Schneider in a paper
强迫思维。这感觉糟透了，但忽视它们，或者极力去压制、去逃避——在那种情况下，这通常是我们觉得唯一自然的反应——很可能会导致它们变本加厉，甚至长出两个脑袋来进一步折磨你。就像这一切，所有和强迫思维相关的事情，老实说都感觉像是个巨大的笑话。这其实是由丹尼尔·瓦格纳（Daniel Wegner）和大卫·施奈德（David Schneider）在20世纪80年代进行的一系列极其著名的研究或实验所证明的，
titled paradoxical effects of thought suppression. Now, you're actually, you have likely heard about this study, even if you don't know the name, even if you don't realize it. It's one of the most famous ones out there. They recruited a number of undergraduate participants at Trinity University and they instructed them to whatever they do, not to think about certain items or certain animals or certain thoughts. The one we all know about is, of course, don't think about a white bear, don't think about a pink elephant. What are you suddenly going to start thinking about those exact things? And basically that's what they reported on. A lot of these participants experienced a noticeable rebound effect where when they were told not to think about something, they actually ended up
论文标题是《思维压制的悖论效应》。现在，你其实……你很可能听说过这项研究，即使你不知道它的名字，即使你没有意识到。这是最著名的研究之一。他们在三一大学招募了许多本科生参与者，并指示他们无论如何都不要去想某些特定的物品、动物或想法。我们都知道的那个例子，当然就是不要去想一只白熊，不要去想一头粉色大象。你突然之间会开始想什么？就会去想那些确切的东西。基本上，这就是他们所报告的结果。许多参与者都体验到了明显的反弹效应，当他们被告知不要去想某事时，
obsessing over it far more than the people who were allowed to think freely about whatever they wanted. they clung onto it. They became obsessive about it. Some of them really were like, oh my God, I can't stop thinking about it. This happens because of something called ironic process theory. Once you have been given the instruction not to think about something, a part of you now has to check that you're not thinking about it. And now has to make sure you're still avoiding the thought.
他们最终对这件事的执念，远超那些被允许自由思考自己想做的事情的人。他们紧抓着不放。他们对此变得无法自拔。其中一些人真的觉得，天哪，我停不下来不去想它。这种情况的发生，是因为有一种叫做“讽刺过程理论”（ironic process theory）的东西。一旦你得到了“不要去想某事”的指令，你的一部分大脑现在就必须去检查你是否没有在想它。现在就必须确保你仍在逃避这个想法。
But how can you know you're not? thinking about it if you're not checking and therefore thinking about it which ironically keeps the thought active and front of mind ironic that's why it's called ironic thought process theory it's very exhausting right the only real way to win this kind of mental tug-of-war game is to give your brain specific permission to think about it for a while or to talk about it any method that gets it out of your brain where it's constantly going to be reinforced is massively helpful partially because that's when we can examine how irrational it actually is. That's hard, right? Because acknowledging an intrusive thought or acknowledging a taboo thought or one that really
但如果你不去看自己有没有在想，从而实际上还是在想它，你又怎么能知道自己没有在想呢？这具有讽刺意味地让这个想法保持活跃并在脑海中占据前台。太讽刺了，这就是为什么它被称为讽刺思维过程理论。这非常消耗精力，对吧？在这种心理拉锯战中获胜的唯一真正方法，是给你的大脑具体的许可，让它想一会儿，或者谈论它。任何能把它从你的大脑中排挤出去的方法——在脑海中它会被不断强化——都是非常有效的，部分原因在于，正是在这个时候，我们可以检验它实际上是多么不切实际。这很难，对吧？因为承认一个强迫思维，或者承认一个禁忌的想法，或者一个真正
scares you or a thought that you don't want to have or that you want to harm your pet, whatever that is, acknowledging that to somebody kind of feels like an endorsement. It kind of feels like we're saying we want to do that. We worry people will misunderstand us. It is the only way through. Is it going to make it more likely to happen now that you've spoken about it? Absolutely not.
吓到你的想法，或者一个你不想有、或者想要伤害你的宠物的想法（无论那是什么），向某人承认这一点，感觉有点像是一种背书。感觉有点像我们在说我们想那样做。我们担心别人会误解我们。但这是通往外界的唯一途径。难道因为你把它说出来了，它就会更有可能发生吗？绝对不会。
It's actually going to make it a lot easier for you to manage this thought because it's not as powerful. The other reason this is so effective, speaking about a thought, acknowledging it, talking about it, is because it stops avoidance. And every time you avoid a thought, you essentially strengthen the belief that there must be some truth to it. And you also strengthen the belief that you can't handle it. When you deliberately allow the thought instead and not allow the action, just allow the thought instead of just like pushing it away really aggressively, you're essentially doing a form of exposure therapy. It's the same principle that's used in
它实际上会让你更容易管理这个想法，因为它不再那么有力量了。这种方法如此有效的另一个原因——谈论一个想法、承认它、讨论它——是因为它阻止了逃避。每一次你逃避一个想法，你本质上就是在强化这样一种信念：这个想法一定有几分道理。而且你也强化了这样一种信念：你无法应对它。当你刻意去允许这个想法存在，而不是允许行动发生；只是允许这个想法存在，而不是像那样极具攻击性地把它推开，你本质上就是在做一种暴露疗法。这与用于
cognitive behavioral therapy or to get rid of phobias. Anxiety and distress in response to a thought works because of avoidance learning. When a thought appears, you panic. Because you panic, you try to neutralize the thought by suppressing it. There's a temporary relief. So your brain learns that avoiding the thought altogether will keep me safe. But of course, it also learns how to overcome that suppression and therefore, reinforces the fear loop that the thought alone is in itself innately scary.
认知行为疗法或摆脱恐惧症的原理是相同的。对一个想法产生焦虑和痛苦的反应，其起因是逃避学习。当一个想法出现时，你会恐慌。因为你恐慌，你就会试图通过压制来中和这个想法。这会带来短暂的缓解。所以你的大脑了解到，完全逃避这个想法会让我保持安全。但当然，它也学会了如何克服这种压制，从而强化了恐惧循环：即这个想法本身天生就很可怕。
When you allow a thought, and again, allow the thought, not the action, the anxiety does still rise. But when you don't neutralize it and nothing catastrophic happens, it will naturally fall. And your nervous system essentially learns, yes, this thought is uncomfortable, but it is not dangerous because it is just a thought. It cannot reach out of my mind and hurt me. That is called habituation or in newer models inhibitory learning. You build a new memory that competes with the fear association.
当你允许一个想法存在——再次强调，是允许想法存在，而不是允许行动——焦虑确实还是会上升。但当你没有去中和它，也没有发生任何灾难性的事情时，它自然就会平息。你的神经系统本质上会学到：是的，这个想法很不舒服，但它并不危险，因为它只是一个想法。它无法从我的脑海里伸出手来伤害我。这被称为习惯化，或者在较新的模型中被称为抑制性学习。你建立了一个与恐惧联结相竞争的新记忆。
The new memory being, this isn't going to hurt me. Traditionally, exposure therapy has been viewed through the lens of fear extinction. The goal is to reduce our fear response over repeated exposure to zero, to never feel fear towards a thought ever again. the inhibitory model says maybe we can never fully eradicate fear and maybe that's okay but we can build and reinforce new competing memories that are if not positive at the very least just neutral and less anxiety inducing and we're able to look at a thought and just see it for what it is similar to this and i actually found this tip in a book called the happiness trap which i think i've mentioned
新的记忆是：这不会伤害我。传统上，暴露疗法是通过恐惧消退的视角来看待的。目标是通过反复暴露，将我们的恐惧反应减少到零，永远不再对一个想法感到恐惧。而抑制性模型则认为，也许我们永远无法彻底消除恐惧，也许这也没关系，但我们可以建立和强化新的、互补的记忆，这些记忆即使不是积极的，至少也是中性的，且较少引发焦虑，让我们能够审视一个想法并看到它的本来面目。类似于这一点——我实际上是在一本名为《幸福陷阱》（The Happiness Trap）的书里找到这个建议的，我想我以前在
on the podcast before. I feel like we have this series, like a couple of books that we mention all the time that are so good, this is one of them. And in this book, there is this method called diffusion that has really helped with my intrusive thoughts. And it has a few elements, but the one I liked the most that the author Russ Harris mentions is to take the thought, to take any intrusive thought and find a way to transform it in some way, whether that's mentally, creatively, physically, to a point where it's not scary anymore. Basically, take the thought, take it out of your brain,
播客里提到过。我觉得我们有这样一系列书，比如有几本书是我们经常提到的，它们太棒了，这就是其中之一。在这本书里，有一种叫做“解离”（diffusion）的方法，对我的强迫思维真的很有帮助。它有几个要素，但我最喜欢、作者拉斯·哈里斯（Russ Harris）提到的一点是：抓住这个想法，抓住任何强迫思维，并找到某种方式来改变它——无论是从精神上、创造性上还是身体上——直到它不再可怕为止。基本上，抓住这个想法，把它从你的大脑里拿出来，
write it down, paint about it, tell somebody about it, but like say, for example, write it down in like big block letters and then color the letters in. Or like imagine the thought or the situation you're scared of, but in the situation everybody has like a red clown nose on.
把它写下来，画出来，或者告诉别人，但比如——举个例子——用大号正楷字把它写下来，然后把字母涂上颜色。或者想象这个想法或你害怕的情境，但在那个情境里，每个人都戴着一个红色的马戏团小丑鼻子。
Or sing the thought to yourself in like a silly voice or be like, oh, like pretend you and this thought are on a talk show and they're a comedian and you're like laughing at this thought. You're like, God, that's a funny one. I'm always reminded when I talk to people about diffusion of that in Harry Potter and the prisoner of Ascaband where they have, I don't know, like a Bogart or something, I don't know what it's called, but they have like that big trunk and like the thing jumps out and it turns
或者用一种滑稽的声音对自己唱出这个想法，或者假装你和这个想法正在做客一档脱口秀节目，它是喜剧演员，而你在嘲笑这个想法。你会想：“天哪，这真搞笑。”每当我和人们谈论解离时，我总是会想起《哈利·波特与阿兹卡班的囚徒》里的那一幕，他们有一个……我不知道，类似于博格特（Bogart）之类的东西，我不知道它叫什么，但他们有一个那个大箱子，然后那个东西会跳出来，变成
into the thing they fear the most and they have to find a way to turn it into a funny thing. So like the spider turns into a spider on roller escapes or like the full moon turns into a deflating balloon. It's interesting because that is this technique. Like that's a real technique. That is diffusion because it makes this thought feel less scary and real and serious and important because you make a joke out of it because you look at it through another angle. Another step of this process and actually it's the first step, I jumped the gun.
他们最害怕的东西，他们必须想办法把它变成一个滑稽的东西。所以蜘蛛会变成踩着旱冰鞋的蜘蛛，或者满月会变成一个正在漏气的气球。这很有趣，因为这就是那个技巧。这真的是个技巧。这就是解离，因为它让这个想法感觉不那么可怕、不那么真实、不那么严肃和重要，因为你拿它开玩笑，因为你从另一个角度看待它。这个过程的另一个步骤——实际上这是第一步，我有点操之过急了，
I jumped ahead. But it's basically just to actually label a thought as it is, which is an intrusive one. It's just to say, like, this is an intrusive thought, nothing more, nothing less. Because the meaning we assign to these thoughts, including our interpretations around responsibility or danger or that they could come true, that is what causes anxiety or distress. But when you can just clearly be like, oh, well, this is just an intrusive thought, I know what this is. I know the anatomy of this thought. I know it's not real. You get your distance.
我提前说了。但它基本上就是把一个想法准确地贴上标签，它就是一个强迫思维。就是说，“这是一个强迫思维，仅此而已，不多不少。”因为我们赋予这些想法的意义——包括我们围绕责任感、危险性或它们可能会成真的解释——才是导致焦虑或痛苦的原因。但当你能清楚地意识到“哦，好吧，这只是一个强迫思维，我知道这是什么。我知道这个想法的解剖结构。我知道这不是真的”时，你就拉开了距离。
It's like providing the diagnosis for the thing that didn't use to have a label. I found that that in itself, just being able to label that, gives me space. Okay, we are going to take one more short break before I have a few rapid fire tips for you that I personally do to keep my intrusive thoughts nice and friendly. So if you want even more solicited or unsolicited advice for me on this topic, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
这就像是为以前没有标签的事物提供了一个诊断。我发现，仅仅是能够贴上这个标签，本身就为我争取到了空间。好了，在我们进入一系列快速小贴士之前，我要进行最后一个简短的休息，这些小贴士是我个人用来让我的强迫思维保持友好状态的。所以，如果你想要我关于这个话题的更多主动或被动建议，请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家进行交流，还有更多内容，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
以此来审视那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在iHeartRadio上的“T-W-O-P-P-Cent”、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. At this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,
其中包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克毒品。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的日子，但只是为了让大家知道。此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论快克，
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。
for black people in American history. Listen to Look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们把人生当作记分牌来观看，生活变成了一场场胜负。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你认为在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟，绝对是。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地去成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《用艰难Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
在2023年，前“钻石王老王”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我只篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，
news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games. You get stupid games. You get stupid. prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by
劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏。你会得到愚蠢的。游戏。你会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这季崭新的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个多产的骗子。我觉得自己就像被一辆卡车
a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
You guys know how much I love a mantra and that they can literally rewire our neurology and our entire thought process and that the words you speak to yourself are important in changing your attitude. and I think this is obviously a great place to use them. The goal here isn't to argue with the thought, but to just introduce a new truth.
你们知道我有多喜欢口头禅，它们确实可以重塑我们的神经系统和整个思维过程，你对自己说的话对于改变你的态度非常重要。我认为这显然是使用它们的好地方。这里的目标不是与这个想法争论，而是引入一个新的真相。
Like all these methods so far have been asking us to do. Some mantras that I find really powerful, yes, one just being like, this is just an intrusive thought, I know how to deal with intrusive thoughts, that's a great one. Some others are, I can feel anxious and still choose my actions. My anxiety does not predict my reaction.
就像到目前为止所有这些方法一直在要求我们做的那样。我发现非常有力的一些口头禅，比如，仅仅是“这只是一个强迫思维，我知道如何处理强迫思维”，这就是一个很好的口头禅。还有一些是：“我可以感到焦虑，但仍然可以选择我的行动。”“我的焦虑并不能预测我的反应。”
I don't actually have to solve this. I can just let the thought exist. Another mantra that I love is just uncertainty isn't dangerous. The unknown isn't dangerous. And this thought cannot harm me because it's just a thought. Having something like a verbal anchor that you can hold on to, like this isn't dangerous or it's just the fear of the unknown, nothing more. Like it provides you with cognitive distance.
“我其实不必非得解决这个问题。我可以让这个想法存在。”我喜欢的另一个口头禅是：“不确定性并不可怕。未知并不可怕。而且这个想法无法伤害我，因为它只是一个想法。”拥有一个你可以抓紧的语言锚点，比如“这并不危险”或“这只是对未知的恐惧，仅此而已”，它能为你提供认知距离。
So you don't develop this inherent belief. that anytime you think something it's representative of your values. No, it's just another way of thinking. It's just a uniquely fearful way of thinking that you don't have to read into. Similar to a mantra too is to literally pull yourself out of your mind and into your body
这样你就不会产生这种根深蒂固的信念：每当你想到什么，就代表了你的价值观。不，这只是另一种思考方式。这只是一种独特的、充满恐惧的思考方式，你无需过度解读。与口头禅类似的做法，也是字面意义上把你从思维中拉出来，进入身体里，
and just say stop out loud to the thought and then grab the nearest object and describe it and like experience the object and give it as much detail as possible. That is basically a grounding technique for when you feel yourself getting stuck on the thought, pull yourself back into reality. Pull yourself back into the present. That tactile physical nature interrupts the mental spiral. Name the things color, name its texture, name its weight, its temperature,
然后对那个想法大声说“停”，接着抓住最近的一个物体并描述它，去体验那个物体，尽可能多地给出细节。这基本上是一种落地技术，当你发现自己卡在某个想法里时，把自己拉回现实。把自己拉回当下。这种触觉、物理上的特性会打断心理的恶性循环。说出物品的颜色，说出它的质地，说出它的重量、温度，
it shape the small details you would normally ignore. This moves the brain from this abstract sense of internal threat and internal fear and trying to process the environment into processing the environment in the present form that it's actually in. It just provides you with a distraction that is vivid enough and real enough that it stops your brain from amplifying the intrusion. You can literally do that with as many objects as many times as you need, even if it just brings you a couple moments of peace.
它的形状，那些你平时会忽视的微小细节。这会将大脑从这种抽象的内部威胁、内部恐惧感，以及试图处理环境的状态，转变为以其实际存在的当前形式来处理环境。它只是为你提供了一个足够生动、足够真实的干扰，从而阻止你的大脑放大这种入侵。你可以字面意义上用尽可能多的物体、根据需要做多少次，哪怕它只能带给你片刻的平静。
I think it's worth it. Another thing I do is I just mentally ride the wave. And like visually, I think of my thought, I think of my intrusive thought, as a wave that I'm riding. I'm in the sun. I'm in the ocean. It's vibrant. I'm feeling the movement of the wave.
我认为这是值得的。我做的另一件事，就是我在精神上乘风破浪。视觉上，我把我的想法，把我的强迫思维想象成我正在驾驭的一道海浪。我在阳光下。我在海洋里。这里充满生机。我能感受到海浪的运动。
And, you know, it's this surge. this surge of the wave, this surge of anxiety, surge of dread of shame. And that can feel like proof that the thought is dangerous, but riding the wave, literally pretending that these thoughts are a wave that's trying to knock me down, and I'm very competent, and I'm just coasting along and the day is still beautiful, lets me feel that surge and feel that peak and then ride with it until it kind of, I guess, disappears. your job is not to flatten the water in this scenario.
你知道的，这是汹涌澎湃的浪潮，海浪的涌动，焦虑的涌动，恐惧与羞耻的涌动。这会让人觉得是这个想法很危险的证据，但乘风破浪——字面意义上假装这些想法是试图把我击倒的海浪，而我非常熟练，我只是在顺流而行，这一天依然美好——让我能够感受到那种汹涌和顶峰，然后随波逐流，直到它……我想，基本上是消失。在这类情景中，你的工作不是把水面抚平。
That would be impossible. Your job is just to stay upright on the board. And it's just to keep moving forward, to keep allowing the flow, keep allowing the wave to pass so that you can go on to the next thought, go on to the next wave. Maybe even, dare I say, enjoy the wave. Any kind of visual activity like this, again, keep focusing in on this, but any kind of visual activity,
那是不可能的。你的工作只是在冲浪板上保持直立。而且只需继续前进，继续允许水流通过，继续让海浪过去，这样你才能进入下一个想法，进入下一波海浪。甚至，我敢说，享受海浪。任何这样的视觉活动——再次强调，继续专注于这一点——任何视觉活动，
imagining the thought is a balloon that gets bigger and bigger and then pops. Imagining the thought is like a string that you like slowly pull from your forehead and are pretending to pull until like it pops out. Like all of that is so good. It works slightly different from the diffusion practice because when you have a physical thing that also is operating here when you're recruiting your body, not just your mind. When you're adding this physical feature,
想象这个想法是一个越来越大然后破裂的气球。想象这个想法就像一根绳子，你从额头上慢慢把它抽出来，假装拉着直到它“啵”的一声弹出来。所有这些都太棒了。它与解离练习略有不同，因为当你有一个实体存在时，当你调动你的身体而不仅仅是大脑时，它也在发挥作用。当你加入这种身体特征时，
it recruits your sensory motor areas of the brain that can kind of interrupt this intrusive part. And it basically just gives your nervous system, I think, a completion signal. Like the wave is finished, the balloon has popped, the string is removed. It's like giving your mind a visual, physical, almost motor-based full stop to a third.
它会调动大脑的感觉运动区，从而能够打断这个强迫的部分。它基本上只是给你的神经系统——我认为——一个完成的信号。就像海浪结束了，气球破了，绳子被抽出来了。这就像是给你的大脑一个视觉上的、身体上的、几乎是基于运动的句号，来结束一个往往如此难以捉摸的想法。
thought that is often so intangible. And finally, I have to say this, if you feel like you have had more intrusive thoughts recently, zoom out a little bit and think about what is going on for you in your life. Because the thoughts usually become more intense under periods of stress. it might be worth actually just thinking about where in your life are you moving too fast and is anxiety really bubbling up right now? Use the intrusive thoughts as an indicator of where you should put your attention, where you should try and make your life a little bit less stressful or overwhelming.
最后，我必须这么说：如果你觉得自己最近有了更多的强迫思维，请把视野稍微放宽一点，想想你生活中正在发生什么。因为在压力时期，这些想法通常会变得更加强烈。实际上，值得思考的是：你生活中的哪个部分正节奏太快？焦虑现在是不是真的在沸腾？把强迫思维当作一个指标，看看你应该把注意力放在哪里，应该在哪里努力让生活变得不那么压力重重或令人窒息。
me. Often experiencing intrusive thoughts causes us to want to avoid the very thing we're having intrusive thoughts about or the very thing that we're obviously overwhelmed about, whether it's our family, whether it's our friends, whether it's traveling, whether it's the future, literally anything. And that can mean, again, that we are pursuing avoidance. But intrusive thoughts are also knowledge and they also are information about about what's going on in your life not what could go on not what you actually do intend to do but just like about stress and about stress levels so just keep engaging in those things that bring you back to the present and are engaging you in what is actually going on around you and what your life circumstances are actually kind of throwing at you
通常，经历强迫思维会让我们想要逃避我们正在产生强迫思维的那件事，或者我们明显感到不知所措的那件事——无论是我们的家庭、我们的朋友、旅行、未来，还是字面上的任何事情。这意味着，我们再次走上了逃避的道路。但强迫思维也是一种知识，它们也是关于你生活中正在发生的事情的信息——不是关于可能会发生什么，不是关于你实际上打算做什么，而只是关于压力和压力水平。所以，继续去做那些能把你拉回当下、让你专注于周围实际发生的事情以及生活现实对你抛出了什么状况的事情，
so that you can, I don't know, so that you can essentially just deal with the root cause first and deal with the thing that's like flowing beneath all these little like stress bubbles of thoughts that just like cling on to the part of your brain that it's going to fear everything the most. And also I will say go and see a psychologist or a counselor or a therapist. I know for me, to be completely candid, I used to think that seeing a professional would maybe trigger my intrusive thoughts even more. I was always worried that they were going to give me another intrusive thought that I hadn't thought of that was going to scare me and that was going to make things worse for me.
这样你就可以……我不知道，这样你基本上就可以首先处理根本原因，处理那些潜伏在所有这些带恐惧情绪的小压力气泡之下的事情，这些小气泡只会紧紧抓住你大脑中最害怕一切的部分。另外我还要说：去看心理学家、辅导员或治疗师。我知道对我而言，坦白来讲，我曾经以为看专业人士可能会更进一步触发我的强迫思维。我总是担心他们会给我带来一个我还没想过的、会吓到我的新强迫思维，从而把事情弄得更糟。
Absolutely not. Like, absolutely not. These people are incredible. There is a reason that therapy gets its flowers and gets its applause because it really does work. And it was this weird thing where I did avoid therapy for so long when I was really struggling with intrusive thoughts because I was just so. terrified of having to talk about them more. That is avoidance. The moment that I was forced to talk
绝对没有。真的绝对没有。这些人太不可思议了。心理治疗之所以能赢得赞誉和掌声是有原因的，因为它真的管用。这真是一件奇怪的事：当我真的很挣扎于强迫思维时，我逃避心理治疗那么久，仅仅是因为我太害怕不得不更多地谈论它们了。这就是逃避。那一刻，当我被迫去谈论
about them more, all those things that I've been saying to you for this episode did come true. Like, I was able to get the distance that I needed. I was able to see that this wasn't reality. I was able to just laugh at it and be like, wow, that is really absurd. So I hope this episode has helped you. I know it was a long one. I know we went into a lot of stuff, but if you have made it this far, I'd love to know. Leave a comment down below if you're listening on Spotify. What's the weirdest intrusive thought you've ever had? I'll go first. I had one recently where I became convinced that in the middle of the night I'd gotten up
它们更多时，我在这集节目里对你们说过的那所有事情真的都应验了。我能够获得我需要的距离；我能够看到这不是现实；我能够对此付诸一笑，心想：“哇，这真的太荒谬了。”所以我希望这集节目对你们有所帮助。我知道这是一期很长的节目，我知道我们探讨了很多内容，但如果你听到了这里，我很想知道。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留言：你经历过的最奇怪的强迫思维是什么？我先来。我最近有过一次，我深信自己在半夜爬起来，
and I'd eaten a whole packet of gum and I'd swallowed it. And I was like convinced. I was like convinced that I was going to die from like a blocked intestine. So there you go. How fun is that? Drop your funniest intrusive thought and we can not laugh at them together obviously but just like, yeah, hopefully it can make you acknowledge how silly they can sometimes be. you guys will have some good ones. Thank you as always again for listening and thank you to our
吃了一整包口香糖，而且把它给吞下去了。我当时确信不疑。我确信自己会因为肠道阻塞而死。所以，就是这样。这有多好玩？留下你最搞笑的强迫思维，我们可以一起不……当然不是去嘲笑它们，而是希望它能让你意识到它们有时是多么愚蠢。你们肯定有一些很有趣的经历。一如既往地感谢大家的收听，也要感谢我们的
researcher Libby Colbert for her help with this episode. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram. If you are not watching the podcast on Netflix, what are you doing if you're in the US in Canada and you are not watching the podcast on Netflix? Well, that's where you need to be. Go and check it out. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对这期节目的帮助。确保你在Instagram上关注了我们。如果你没有在Netflix上观看这个播客，你在干什么？如果你在美国或加拿大，却没有在Netflix上观看这个播客？好吧，那才是你应该去的地方。去看看吧。直到下期节目，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app,
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在iHeartRadio上的“TWA%”、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中 对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻 84年对我意义重大 我是萨姆·J 我是亚历克斯·英格利什 每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people Listen to Look Back at it
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的 我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员 以及最喜欢的作家 比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代 84年是疯狂的一年 我不认为对黑人来说 还有比这更重要的年份了 在《Look Back at It》中收听
On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
在iHeartRadio应用程序 Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方 嗨，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《用艰难的方式学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全去展开的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，“钻石王老王”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我只篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he did. serves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他不会就这么逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。